[Música]
la movilización indígena llegó a la
capital ecuatoriana partieron desde el
sur de ecuador para llegar al parque del
arbolito icono de la concentración
popular el gobierno desde el presidente
sixto durán ballén 1992-1996 un lugar
estratégico por su cercanía a la
asamblea nacional en la presidencia de
la república donde se producen protestas
con mucha frecuencia en el país andino
este es el mismo lugar desde el año 2019
en el que los movimientos indígenas
exigieron actual presidente alí moreno
quiere derogar el decreto que contempla
la eliminación de los subsidios
combustibles y paralizó el país durante
11 días en fuertes protestas en las
última década este ha sido escenario
para rechazar a todos los gobiernos hoy
se concentra para reclamar un supuesto
fraude electoral enmarcado en la primera
vuelta electoral de cara a la
presidencia de la república
más de 16.000 actas que tienen
inconsistencias
vamos a presentar y qué orden las
palabras hombre los acuerdos
practique lo que esté la ley para de
esta manera que se reabran la
las urnas ideales de las 24 provincias
pero por lo menos para nosotros va a
salir de palabra el tiempo siente en
guayas y el 50 por ciento de las 16
provincias en algún momento se
realizaron la impresión de 6 millones de
papeletas man impresas alguien decía que
estaba en custodia pero que nos indique
si en realidad está en custodia porque
nos vinieron a informar que ha decidido
utilizar esas papeletas de la
concentración del parque el arbolito
salieron a caminar hacia la fiscalía
general de la república y asia consejo
nacional electoral asegurando que
presentaran 16 mil pruebas de actas que
prueban el fraude que han comentado
llegaron al consejo nacional electoral
asegurando que sería la última
oportunidad que le darían al órgano
comicial no a pesar de ello éste no se
ha manifestado sobre la propuesta de
realizar un peritaje informático o de
abrir las urnas
[Música]